it's a very exciting time over at
microcosmos.store right now not only
have we just restocked our original
microcosmos microscope but we also have
a new model of our microscope available
that comes with plan agramatic
objectives but fear not if you have the
original microscope and would like to
upgrade your objectives we have a set of
four plan objectives available for
purchase and we've got individual 20x
and 60x plan objectives available for
purchase as well but that's not all
we've still got our micro Cosmos
sweatshirt available as well as our
tardigrade and Hydra shirts we've also
got a new micro Cosmos mug that lets you
tell the people around you exactly how
many tardigrades you could squish into
your new favorite coffee mug and last
but not least we've got our micro Cosmos
sticker pack which includes some of the
designs from our artist series t-shirts
as well as a brand new tardigrade
Enthusiast micro bumper sticker so if
you're looking to do some holiday
shopping for the tardigrade Enthusiast
in your life or just for your own
tardigrade Enthusiast self head on over
to microcosmos.store and be sure to
order soon if you want to guarantee
delivery Before Christmas
[Music]
if we were to watch this video together
with our usual microcosmos mindset our
Focus would be on that bristle worm
inching its way through the background
we would watch it poke its head around
as its body sharpens and blurs under the
lens of our microscope and those bright
shining objects it fumbles its way
through would simply be props for our
wormy star providing a bit of a mythical
quality to its surroundings that make it
even harder to tear our gaze away from
the screen we might treat those grains
of sand the same way we treat bits of
leaves or Moss or branches that decorate
our other slides which is to say we
might note them and then we would move
on but not today today we're going to
shift our focus and let those grains be
the focus of our show more specifically
we are going to talk about sand
foreign
our master of microscopes gets samples
of sand from beaches all over the world
to help in his quest to learn more about
interstitial ciliates the single-celled
organisms that live in the watery
Pockets that exist between grains of
sand on the beach in a previous episode
we have explored the ways these
organisms have adapted to the chaotic
Maze of sharp sand grains that is always
shifting and crashing around them with
the waves but for this episode we're
going to experience that sand in a more
chill way so that we can appreciate just
how beautiful it is on its own
now most of the grains you see in our
sand samples are quartz gleaming with
this rainbow Sheen as polarized light
from our microscope hits them bouncing
off the silicon and oxygen atoms
arranged within the mineral the process
of making these sand grains at the beach
is like an endless Voyage it begins with
the wearing down of rocks as physical
and chemical forces slowly chip away at
them and send pieces sailing down rivers
and streams and eventually those pieces
will reach the ocean where the waves and
Tides around them erode the pieces even
smaller not all of the minerals that
Journey to the ocean will last as long
as these grains do some of them are more
unstable making it easier for them to
break down but quartz and other minerals
like feldspar are more durable and that
keeps them around for much much longer
but over time the ocean will wear those
bits of sand down into finer and finer
grains this ceaseless process has been
going on in some beaches for thousands
of years if not longer and the result is
perhaps a reflection of what beaches can
be in general a place that brings things
or people from far away and yet they
reflect the local environment as well
the minerals and tourists may be distant
but the essence is far more specific
after all beaches are not just sand and
water they are also ecosystems full of
life
which means yes that they must also be
full of death
[Music]
there are of course the fragmented
shells that have been washed to shore
hinting at creatures large and small
whose bodies relied upon them for
protection
and then there are structures like that
single point Lancing through the middle
of this slide like a transparent needle
that was once part of the exoskeleton of
a sponge a part called a spicule that
acted like a brick glued together by a
collagen-like material called spongen
there's another spicule here on the
right side of your screen with three
transparent ends radiating out from the
center these structures are unique to
each species of sponge their shape and
size and chemical makeup a marker of
their identity that sense of
individuality makes spicules kind of
like sand the minerals that accumulate
into sand grains reflect the geology of
whatever has shaped the beach to begin
with and you don't always need a
microscope to see those influences
perhaps most starkly you can think of
the black sand beaches of Hawaii made
from the erosion of volcanic material
like basalt rock but even the more
mundane brown sand you might typically
associate with beaches tells a story the
brown color is the result of minerals
like feldspar or iron oxide which can
render quartz into that brownish color
but in beaches where quartz begins to
exceed those other materials the result
is white sand though not all white sand
is quartz in fact not all beaches are
simply a matter of rocks sometimes they
are literal tons of poop really in
Hawaii the parrotfish will eat algae
that grow on coral reefs which means the
parrotfish might also ingest some of the
coral itself after digestion the
parrotfish oop out the calcium carbonate
from the coral which makes its way to
the beach as white sand
and these are not the only beaches whose
beauty is shaped by the life that lives
in nearby Waters in Bermuda the famous
pink of their beaches is the result of
unicellular organisms called
foraminifera which live in calcium
carbonate shells like the swirls you see
here within those beaches those shells
eventually get broken down and washed to
Shore and reddish pigments within them
color their new surroundings these
foraminifera though don't seem to have
had the same pinkish effect on the sand
where their shells ended up the
conditions around them created a
different landscape a distinct and
multi-faceted identity told through the
Kaleidoscope of countless grains a
reminder that on this planet wherever
you look the biology is geological and
the geology is biological
foreign
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you to all
the people whose names are on the screen
right now these are our patrons on
patreon we love that we get to take some
pieces of glass arranged in a very
specific configuration and point them at
things to see things that were entirely
hidden to the vast majority of humans
and we get to share that with you if you
would like to join you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes you can check out jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
foreign